we've finally got the first trailer for
Aquaman and let's just say I'm digging
it
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the top five
moments and Easter eggs and the epic
comic-con trailer for Aquaman and just
before we start if you're new here be
sure to subscribe to stay up-to-date
with all my superhero and comic-con
videos the underwater world of Aquaman
that director James Wan will be bringing
to the big screen looks pretty
breathtaking
comic book fans will likely be extremely
happy at the level of comic book
accuracy and the world building going on
here is fantastic for example those
sharks and sea dragons with their riders
are amazing to see in action and jumping
ahead in the trailer we have to talk
about the incredible awesomeness of the
underwater wall that's teased and
bringing the wrath of the seven seas
with me
[Music]
let's just go back over the epicness of
it all to check the details behind that
huge school of sharks advancing there's
some tentacle craft that look a bit like
squids or they may be octopus inspired
and as they advance on the army of giant
crab and lobster like creatures I love
the way these giant alligators or Tyler
sauce swim in and go in for the kill on
one of the crustaceans talking of
battles Black Manta looks amazing and
I'm bringing the wrath of the seven seas
with me this is a very comic book
accurate costume for this second villain
and James Wan has said that the movie
will reveal how black manta got his
costume and how he can shoot plasma
beams out of his bug-eyed helmet the
actor who plays him is said that black
manta is simply out for revenge on
Aquaman and he's not planning to take
over the world or anything like that
from the trailer it looks like the cause
of black mantas grievance against Arthur
curry will be when Aquaman attacks a
submarine that he's hijacked with some
other mercenaries by the way it looks
like Black Manta will be used as a porn
by Aquaman's main villain Arthur's
brother or who wants to bring war to the
surface world there's a glimpse of that
when Black Manta wreaks havoc with his
laser eyes on a town's rooftops right
let's go back to the water for yet
another visual feast when Aquaman and
Mira encounter creatures from the trench
James Wan is a master of horror movies
and these moments are in homage to the
type of scary monsters in Creature from
the Black Lagoon this is a scene where
the trench people attack a boat to kill
and eat the people on board and it looks
like Aquaman and Mira are using a Fleur
to draw or scare them away the visual
look of this scene is stunning and the
way the creatures swarm into the ocean
like a horde of ants to chase after
Aquaman a mirror is epic the filmmakers
have said that the trench people are
like the mold people of the sea they
don't actually have any eyes so I'm
curious to find out exactly how the
Fleur works to draw them away from the
boat by the way I'm also getting a touch
of alien xenomorph Phibes from one of
the close-up shots of the trench
creatures in the footage and if you
enjoyed the theme in the trailer you
might not have realized that it's
actually a cool musical Easter Egg to
Batman V Superman specifically the
trailer for the Ultimate Edition so
overall I really dug
this trailer but I'm not totally sure
about some of the corny one-liners that
was the worst pep talk though some of
them are probably gonna be crowd
pleasers permission to come aboard
also some of the green-screen was a bit
noticeable and a few sequences but
that's pretty normal at this stage and
VFX are often improved between trailer
releases and the final theatrical
release so hopefully that's the case
here - so what did you think about the
Aquaman trailer and what were the best
moments for you let's discuss more in
the comments and do leave a like if you
enjoyed this video
tapleft for more movie breakdowns
including Easter eggs you missed in the
glass trailer plus my Godzilla 2 trailer
analysis or tap write for more superhero
and comic-con videos thanks for watching
and see you next time you became movie
lovers